who Scott Israel and what do we really
know about him well he's that colorful
brash outspoken Broward County Sheriff
who's been speaking for law enforcement
since the Valentine's Day Massacre at
Stoneham Douglass High School just eight
days after the shooting before his
department had even concluded its own
investigation
sheriff Israel found time to join a CNN
Town Hall where he decided to join
forces with the pro-gun control lobby
[Music]
[Applause]
they're not adults yet they're gold
they're in high school these kids should
not have a rifle automatic rifles should
be outlawed forever and anybody who says
different I don't know about other
people but amber and I we're calling BS
on that I'm sorry but he's such a
blowhard I mean the sheriff had to know
that
automatic weapons that he referenced in
that soundbite were banned by the feds
years ago and that the NRA does not
advocate for legalizing them Sheriff you
got to know that or you shouldn't be in
that job at all but who the heck cares
cuz it sounded good in front of that
crowd and it brought the audience to its
feet and just a few days later Israel
revealed the existence of videotape and
a little piece of information that I
thought was kind of important well what
I saw was a deputy arrived at the west
side of building 12 take up a position
and he never went in well once that
choice piece of information became
public and more began to trickle out
about the department's handling of at
least 23 calls to the crews residence
Florida Governor Rick Scott and others
asked for sheriff Israel's resignation
now yesterday the not camera-shy sheriff
was asked about the calls for him to
step down
I've given amazing leadership to this
age amazing leaders I've work
yes J got this there's a lot of things
we've done throughout this this is a you
you don't measure a person's leadership
you don't measure a person's leadership
well yes we do measure a person's
leadership look police and Broward wear
body cameras and we know there was
security camera footage because
authorities refused to publicly release
it we're not going to disclose the video
at this time and we may never disclose
the video depending on the prosecution
and the criminal case that seems really
bogus to me and really weird we may
never release the video we've already
seen video of the kids leaving the
building and so why won't the sheriff
release the video that would arguably be
of the most interest to the public now
the video reveals how officer Peterson
and other deputies responded to this
active shooter situation it's kind of
important don't you think now could it
be that the video would be perhaps
highly damaging to the sheriff's office
and perhaps to the sheriff personally
and back to his appearance at that CNN
town hall meeting why on earth did he
choose to go on TV to make himself the
center of this heated political debate
is that really his role then he went on
television the next week just yesterday
to praise his own leadership as amazing
it's just bizarre and the Latin by the
way this wasn't the first time sheriff
Israel ignited controversy for making
himself the main attraction back in
September of 2015
he took major heat for putting his big
face on five taxpayer-financed Broward
Sheriff's Office cars now they were
called jokingly Israel mobiles and to a
lot of people they just look at him they
were more about politics and policing
although it's a very good rap of that
'mobile now the cars were to be assigned
to members of israel's community
outreach team which itself had been
staffed by it looks like just the
sheriff's campaign supporters he got
hammered for that as well well just a
few hours ago the Ingram angle received
copies of internal emails from a source
close to the Broward Sheriff's Office
which has since been confirmed by a
second source this this evening by one
of our producers now it urges all staff
members to vigorously support sheriff
Israel in Reed's and partner part at the
moment we find our agency up against a
flurry of media allegations in a
personal attack against our sheriff
sheriff Israel it's sheriff Israel stood
with us and now we must stand with him
it's important that they know we stand
as one
hmm the focus should be on getting to
the bottom of what happened leading up
to the shooting not some cya deal for
the sheriff we need to know about the
actions of law enforcement on the day of
the shooting shouldn't be about saving
Sheriff Israel's job because that would
be really pathetic now the governor
yesterday announced that Florida's
Department of law enforcement will
investigate Broward County's response to
the shooting with which sheriff Israel
said he would cooperate fully now
President Trump met with the governor's
today at the White House and they
discussed school safety and the
aftermath of the parklands shooting we
have to take steps to harden our schools
so that they're less vulnerable to
attack
this includes allowing well trained and
certified school personnel to carry
concealed firearm it's at some point you
need volume well before this
administration in the end embarks on
some legislative response to the
shooting the president should request
that attorney general sessions open his
own federal investigation into this
entire matter and that means not only
examine what happened
that horrible day but also the FBI's
failure to follow up on critical tips
the school's internal disciplinary
records and Broward's own interactions
with Cruz and his family know
law-abiding Americans Second Amendment
rights should be diluted or compromised
before we know exactly what happened
from the moment that first distress call
came in to the Broward Sheriff's Office
and sheriff Israel should spend a lot
less time patting himself on the back
and a lot more time being transparent
with the public that demands answers and
that's the angle